hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie sorry I was a few minutes
late I went to hit the button to start
the stream and I realized that the
camera wasn't on so I I don't know if it
just wasn't working all day and I didn't
notice I didn't really have OBS up until
a few minutes before the stream so I
wouldn't known but anyway everything
should be working now and let me move
this over let's let's uh make that
bigger and now move this over here and
this should work now there we are and
I'm gonna paste the end rock link for
you all there we go okay
so first thing I'm gonna do is go over
some changes that I've made so I've been
doing I don't like a decent amount of
work on this myself over the last like
day or two so when I want to make sure
we're on the same page with where we're
at and what I need to do I'm gonna fill
you in on how my presentation went
yesterday so for those of you who are
first-time viewers or just you know
maybe haven't seen that much in this
show I my day-to-day work as a front-end
developer for a small University so
there's gonna be mistakes
we're there's gonna be interruptions so
it's not exactly tutorial it's just it's
just my everyday work this is what I do
and I don't prepare anything and I don't
try to make it look any better or worse
than it really is so having said that
we're working on a site and this is
going to be the main website for the
university it was supposed to launch
by the end of this month we were on
pretty good track I think it was gonna
be I was gonna have to work late you
know probably for a week or so but I
think we were gonna be able to launch
with the minimum you know that we needed
but some people higher up have decided
that we're not gonna launch them that I
basically I need to meet with a bunch of
different people all over the university
present the site to them
and get some feedback and then launch at
some later date to be determined so I
don't even have another date yet I did
the first of those meetings yesterday it
was okay I think you know I I didn't get
a standing round of applause which I
didn't really expect to get anyway but I
didn't really get negative feedback from
anyone so there are some features that
they seem to to like the speed they like
the speed I had n rock up and I let
everybody load it on their phones so
they could check out how it looks on a
mobile and what else it they like the
ability to go in and edit so I actually
went into WordPress and showed at that
particular department we're in our
WordPress installation they would go to
edit their own content and then I I
showed them how easy it would be and so
I think they liked those features so not
bad wasn't a really big presentation it
was just one small department and there
are actually some people missing from
the presentation so it was even smaller
than I thought it was going to be some
work we're talking like I don't know
maybe like seven people if that so some
of my other presentations would probably
be bigger next then my next presentation
is gonna be a big one I I meet with all
the all the bosses all the vice
presidents and and stuff and I'm gonna
present it to them so having said all
that it's kind of a big intro this is
where we're at right now
the project we've kind of put everything
else on hold and we're trying to make
this site look as nice as we can for
some certain like key pages so that when
I present it it looks as finished as
possible even though we know you know in
the background it's not finished we
don't have all the data migrated so if
before each presentation I'm gonna
handpick certain pages and certain
pieces of data even if we have to hard
code them in it doesn't really matter we
just need to make sure those pages are
ready so for yesterday's presentation I
made sure it was the student life
department so I made sure that the
student life page had all the data on it
right otherwise he probably wouldn't
worried about that page till later on
down the road but that's how it's gonna
go so I'm gonna have to determine what
content would be best to have on the
site for this next presentation for all
the you know the VIPs of the vice
president's and and so on of this
University so I'm not really that
worried about it surprisingly but I know
you know other people were kind of
nervous that are gonna be in the
presentation with me so I do want to do
a good job so here's what we're going to
do today we're gonna make some
components to try to clean up this
homepage because I was looking it was
huge
right so I've already begun to do some
of that and as we go through the code
I'll show you what I pulled out and what
components I created and we wanna we're
gonna add a section here so we're gonna
add a little section that's going to be
full width and pretty much just text but
it's going to be a little bit of
explanation about what this university
is about what the what the mission is
for the university and that's going to
kind of introduce students prospective
students for the main audience so they
come here they're going to see maybe not
this picture I just put this picture in
to try it out let me know what you all
think the last picture I had
there was a landscape shot and the head
of my department didn't really like that
picture so now I've decided to go with a
shot of actual students see if I kind of
prefer that I think there's kind of a
connection when you see a person's face
and this is kind of kind of nice right
everyone's smiling it seems like I don't
know like hey people are happy here
I don't know let me know what you all
think I really want your input on this
I've been going through pictures in fact
like the first half-hour I was here this
morning I just spent the whole time
going through images trying to figure
out what to put in here so we're gonna
try this and as the student Scrolls down
then they're going to get a little bit
about the mission of the University and
they're gonna have the we're gonna put a
button in there that's going to let them
go on to read more more about that the
university actually has this gigantic
like mission and vision statement is
huge but anyway then they're gonna come
down and they're gonna see more of this
and my boss wants me to have more like
this where we actually say what the
content is so instead of just having a
card that's just an image or just a
video we're gonna have you know two
titles there so it's going to say on
basically what this video is about or
what this is an image of and we're gonna
add some more profiles in there so we'll
get as much done as we can in about an
hour I do have to go and pick my kids up
in about an hour and 15 minutes I have
to leave for that so I'm just gonna keep
that in mind and I just realized that I
don't have any music going it's because
I restarted my computer all right
I can't possibly code without my music
right
all right cool so I am getting some
feedback on the images and on the the
new thing so let's start with that
because that's the first thing we could
probably work on here
hey everybody that's saying I know I
appreciate it thanks for watching Chris
says love your videos thank you for the
hard work and the time you put into them
oh no problem thanks for saying that I'm
happy that lets you enjoy the videos so
Saad says white text on white background
is hard to read yeah I think so too I
did darken it so I put let me show you
how I did this where's my and I can
introduce you to a component that I've
made as well while we're doing this so I
took that ol hero section and I made
this component called hero so now on
interior pages we could pop in this hero
component if we want to and other pages
can have hero sections so I am here's
here's how I did this I actually put in
in line was
okay I split all this stuff out there is
our actual return there's our actual
return okay so because I wanted to be
able to pass a prop that's an image URL
that's why I'm doing the style here in
line but I've added a linear gradient
first so the background image can take
multiple things as what the background
will be and it just stacks them on top
so the first thing you put in will be on
the top right and then after that or
just layer so you can put in multiple
images whatever you want so in this case
we started out with a linear gradient
and I just put the same two values for
the linear gradient so normally it'll go
like it'll go from one value to the
other like gradually well if you put the
same value it's just an overlay
basically of all the same color
so in this case we just did black but we
made it transparent so it's only about
20% right now so that's how what I tried
to do to make it a bit more readable I'm
open to other options but this is
something that standard that can
increase readability no matter what
image we put in there so I like it as
kind of a standard thing for this
component to be reusable but I'm
definitely open to doing something
different especially for the homepage so
and this component has a lot of props to
it so it's not it's not ideal right now
let me get rid of some stuff I was
working on them finished with so I can
show you let me know if the the font
needs to be larger for this so here's
that euro component and there's a lot in
here but this this is using every single
option that the component has so if you
leave out some of these the component
will just render differently so probably
most of the time when we use this we're
not going to use all the options in
there
so it won't be so huge but for right now
it's it's just a lot of stuff for one
component but still takes a lot less
space than the actual code for all that
so anyway yeah I agree that this is hard
to read one thing I am going to do is I
would like to increase the font size for
this line and for these buttons
hopefully that'll make things a little
bit easier to read so we can mess around
with that here to make these inverted
buttons I also had to make another
component so I guess I should just show
that component now since we're at that
part
I made this inverted button component
because what I found was that you
couldn't change the hover color there
wasn't an easy way to change the hover
color using the the material UI button
component so I wanted to keep using that
but I also wanted to be able to change
the color so here's what I did I went
into the repo for material UI I
completely copied everything in there
for their button component
I changed the paths so if they would
work because these paths were relative
paths before assuming that this was
located in the node modules folder so I
changed those out and it's really simple
anywhere that add a dot dot slash I just
replaced the dot dot with material you I
so down here where we have our flat
secondary button because this happened
to be the buttons that I was using on
the hero section there I change the
hover background to white and then I
added in a color to this this green
color to the official green color for
the University and that allowed me to
have this this effect while still using
the button component so
it's actually kind of cool the only
problem with this is that as material UI
updates it could potentially break
what's going on in here so I'm gonna
have to keep an eye on that it may not
be the final solution but as I said you
know earlier we need solutions that are
going to work fast
for the presentations and we can always
come back later and and fix them but for
now this is kind of cool it works and it
gives us complete control over these
buttons to do whatever we want so you
see there's a ton of options here so I'm
a little bit excited as we go on to kind
of go in here and just figure out more
about how material works like the
internal stuff that's hidden away in the
node modules and and try to change it a
little bit don't think it'll be fun but
anyway it did solve our problem as you
can see we're gonna have to use it for
this as well because we we don't have
the right color here so we have to
change this I don't know if we'll do
that today or not we'll see I added in a
new logo so my department head wanted to
have this logo especially on the desktop
but as I was looking this works as long
as we don't add anything here which we
don't plan to this does work you know I
think I'm worried about it's on a really
small screen but if it if it checks out
it works even on a really small screen
you might keep it that's too big let's
go on this iPhone 4 is tiny yeah see it
doesn't work on the small screen so
we're gonna have to do something to
switch out for the other logo to like
let's go big again so I can show you
it's like this version of a logo so
we'll switch that out but otherwise this
logo is okay I probably need to make it
a bit bigger but those are pretty much
the the biggest things that I've changed
lately I've done some work with interior
pages
let me check out some of the other
suggestions that we got right off the
bat
someone says Steubenville with an
exclamation point so g jr j r y a n so J
ryan rocks is that how you say it anyway
do you know Steve oh are you from
Stephenville let me know let's see John
said nice tip for that linear gradient
cool yeah I can't remember where I
learned that if I did remember I
definitely give credit to where I
learned that from I think it was a blog
somewhere maybe it was CSS tricks I
can't remember for sure yeah but it's
like such an easy way to put a gradient
on I remember trying to put like divs
inside of divs to do gradients and it's
like no this is this is so simple all
right well okay Jeff says you can make
the gradient variable variable as well
yeah you could we could make a prop for
a gradient so I did have to stop myself
I was going crazy with all the props to
customize it and I just had to stop and
say like honestly we're using this
component once as of right now do I
really need to make all these props so
we you know I'll probably need that
props as we go on but no sense in trying
to like think of everything we possibly
could need right off the bat Jeff says I
think there needs to be more space
between faith and life in the search
icon yeah definitely yeah this got
messed up somewhere along the line and
I'm not sure what I did but I don't
think it was always like this but it's
definite need changed
J Brian Rock says when you get that
color straightened out you can sell it
to slack and make a zillion bucks they
need to fix the color of the highlights
so that the dark background themes work
okay all right so let's let's get into
some code can we do you know what let me
let's put in this section here we're
gonna make a component called tech
section and so primarily it's going to
take as props a link in case there needs
to be a button and then a block of text
that right off the bat we need those two
props we might be able to think of some
other props that we'll need but this
will be a section that I'm sure will be
repeated in various places so let's make
that component and then we'll put that
component in there and have that that
kind of intermediate section you know
what let's take four props right off the
bat let's do the the - I just said text
and then a link the link will be
optional if we don't have a link we
won't render a button and actually if
we're gonna have a link then we need to
add a link text so will be of three and
then we're gonna add a background color
and a font color so we're gonna have
five props and that should be enough to
have some nice customization the only
other thing I could think of right now
is a title maybe we should just add a
title drop in yeah so we're gonna end up
with six props so we're gonna make
component we're gonna have those six
props and then we're going to have the
section in and then it'll be really easy
for us to just add in sections wherever
any pages we want so we're kind of
making some building blocks to build out
some really good-looking pages quickly
we can
make hero sections quickly and we're
about to be able to make tech sections
quickly and then we can we can move
pretty fast and build out some pages for
these presentations there was another
question and I can answer this why I'm
doing that so someone asked what kind of
music others do Peter asked what kind of
music I listen to right now I'm
listening to my top songs of 2016
playlist on Spotify which is a mix of a
lot of dubstep and the Creed soundtrack
so from you know the the Rocky movie
right Creed creed soundtrack and then
acoustic covers of songs so yeah that's
that's a lot of what it is and then yeah
I'd say that covers probably like 90% of
what's in on this playlist right now I
really listen to pretty much anything
the only thing that I consistently don't
like is country music everything else I
will listen to depends on the mood I'm
on or mood I'm in alright so we need a
new component so let's start out with a
blank file new file we're gonna call
this text section and let's grab let's
grab this hero component just to give us
the base now I'm starting out all my
components as class components we can go
back later and refactor into stateless
functional components if that's what we
want but I find it easier to go from a
class to stateless than to go from state
leads to a class so that's why I'm
starting out with the classes even
though it might be overkill for a lot of
the components that we're making all
right so what are we gonna need we're
definitely you need typography we're
gonna keep this inverted button and the
grid alright cool so we have a lot of
what we need already we can get rid of
see here a button an inverted button
let's keep these styles for now because
I think we can reuse some of them with
just a little bit of editing so that'll
save us some time
let's get rid of a lot of this and then
let's let's type out all the props that
we know we're going to need here so
we're doing some D structuring here so
that we don't have to keep typing this
props but this will be a nice list so
that we don't forget what props we want
so as I said we're gonna have title sex
actually let's make this section title
text I wanted to make it section Saito
because title is actually an attribute
that you can put on some elements so I
don't like to have the same names so
that no one gets confused when they're
looking at things so we have the text we
will have a button link button text and
color let's go to say text color and
background background color I said oh
yeah I think that's it all right cool so
we have these not let's go in here and
we can get rid of pretty much all these
constants you can see in this component
I made all these constants because a lot
of these are they're contingent upon
whether or not a prop is there so it's
just a lot cleaner when we pull these
out into their own constants so that we
can say you can easily see like if title
text is there make a title if the
subtitles there make a subtitle right if
the primary button text secondary button
text or tertiary button text is present
then let's let's start rendering this
grid that contains buttons right for the
buttons I like to do both what
and link so if there's not text and the
link we you know we don't render it has
to have both right no sense having a
button that links somewhere but no text
or the other way around so anyway that's
kind of a nice like an easy way to clean
up your components without actually
having to make a lot of other components
and link them up alright so anyway let
me get rid of these and I did I use the
word tertiary for the third button is
that word well-known enough that it's
okay like is everybody know what
tertiary is I know you'll use that word
often but I mean it was the correct word
like if we were using like primary
secondary it's it's definitely the
correct one but I'm a little I was a
little bit nervous that people wouldn't
necessarily know especially like maybe I
think this is not the first your first
language maybe even if English is your
first language nobody uses that word
anymore anyway let me know if you think
that would be an issue because I do want
this code to be like readable okay now
we can take pretty much all of this
let's go yeah let's take out this first
and yeah we definitely want this out of
here we can leave the div so we're gonna
need a div and the class name parallax
weird if we can just make this a grid so
we need that grid container right grid
and then at the top grid we make a
container don't we and you're there
a great container and then we're gonna
have a grid
and I think I wish you'd do this
I don't like to Center things but I'm
almost positive I'm gonna get asked to
Center it
let's just not Center this and then see
if I can get by without without
centering this so I think I do want to
make this first section just a div and
then the tip is going to be full width
so hopefully all right senator senator
just actually I really I like these I
want I don't want a min how you right
now we don't need anything with this
background stuff we won't need that I'm
not gonna Center this least not yet and
I leave these buttons for now
so I'm not gonna worry about the the
grid component yet I'm just gonna throw
in some normal components typography go
to use here I need to go back to the
here let's move our hero section over
here so I can see what typography I used
here
all right we use the display to up there
we try that typography type display too
and yeah it was good
go to our bottom just go with that and
then we're gonna put in here I'm gonna
say it was section title section title
goes in there and then we can close out
our typography tag all right and then
let's to grab this as well and let's put
text here and we're gonna display that
as it's a normal setting for text
[Music]
I should just look up so like I don't
have these stocks open typography area
where's the type shows in classes color
variants okay now its variant we didn't
update to this this one yet so where it
says variant we're gonna use tight but
just so you know if you get the latest
version use variant instead we're gonna
have to update everything at some point
but I don't want to do it right now
because I got to focus on getting things
ready for this presentation body okay
that's what we need let's just use body
one then see how it goes
body one cool alright so yes there's fog
rafi let's add in buttons what do you
have buttons yeah let's just add in
let's grab this put it in here and we'll
change it
we'll just call it button and we're
gonna change this to button link and
we're going to change this to button
text okay we're gonna have to pull in
inverted button oh we already have it
cool all right
so we have that now down here we can
just render button and we're going to
conditionally render these but right now
I'm I'm not worried about that I just
want to make sure it works first before
we do all the conditional stuff that way
if something doesn't work it's going to
be a lot easier to figure out why it's
not working okay one more no that's it
right it's only need for now we can put
in the text color and background color
so let's do that color
yes
yes I don't really yeah I don't need
that right now but I don't want to get
an error because I haven't used those so
let's just go and say for now text color
background-color now it's just not gonna
give me an error when I try to do this
and why is I make I'm getting an error
here up I have him outside the div there
we go we never changed the name of this
component so it's not here oh it is text
section and I forgot to set my timer
sorry about that so it's definitely time
for me to take a break so let's do that
where's my index that's it
yeah I'm just gonna bring this up so I
don't forget where we are but when we
I'm gonna take a five-minute break I'm
gonna answer some questions when we come
back to the code I'm going to import
this component that we just made put
some props in see how how it looks then
we can adjust styles and everything like
that for now I am going to remember my
timer this time would you do a short
break and I'm going to start at the top
of the chat and just scroll down and try
to get to all the comments and questions
i Grimm asked about the media query for
the small screen size I yes so we for
media queries we are using where is it
at
I just deleted a media query from
something so I don't know if we're using
it anymore there's a way to do media
queries within material UI so is so we
have these breakpoints so you can go and
put theme breakpoint and this is up so
on any screens medium and up the
background color changes to red in this
case so for the route component it's
blue normally on medium and up it's red
so that's how we're gonna do it so we're
just do thin breakpoints down and then
we'll put small in here and then we'll
be able to change for small screens so
what we'll probably end up doing for the
app bar is I think right now I'm
directly putting the image in what may
end up doing is making the image a
background image so that we can control
it right from from these styles and use
breakpoints and I think that's going to
end up being the easiest way to do it
and for a bi image I mean I'm talking
about switching out this image for small
screens
Sud says for design and layout ideas you
should check universities websites these
will give you some good ideas about your
website
yeah I've I do check out university
sites from time to time I'm I'm a little
bit torn so I want there to be some
familiarity so that we users come to the
site they understand what's going on but
I also want to make this unique you know
I mean some it's my design and
development not just me you'll help a
lot but like we're working on this and I
kind of I want it to be unique I wanted
to break the mold a little about what
university sites you know are doing so
I'm trying to balance that so I've
actually what I do get inspiration for
is for small details from the way other
sites do things so like we looked at for
our list component we looked at the
newsstand app that's made by Google and
we look at one piece of that newsstand
app and got some ideas for how to
display our content so I like doing that
more than like in terms of like a whole
layout I don't know I find like your
site looks more unique in that way I
don't know but if anybody seems a really
cool University site or other site that
you think would be good inspiration for
something we're doing here let me know
because I definitely check it out and
see if it's you know something we could
use for this project or even a different
one
um MRA AMR is the name so I'm not sure I
pronounced have a last name is awesome
so says hey wish me luck in my quiz
tomorrow good luck I hope you do well in
your quiz let let us know next week how
you do on your quiz let's see Jay Ryan
Rock says tertiary means mix from two
other things right in color so I assume
it's like one generation removed
otherwise yet right I wasn't even
thinking about colors for tertiary but I
was thinking more of like primary being
like well first secondary second
tertiary third so I guess I could have
gone like first button second button
third button that would have been maybe
that would have been a easier I guess I
kind of wanted like primary button and
then there's going to be two secondary
button so I thought about doing
secondary one in secondary to that might
actually make more sense than tertiary
maybe I'm just making a big deal about
nothing
yeah maybe maybe I'll change it let's
see
I think I got everything all the
questions almost all of them Oh Nicky
says for stateless to class select the
function and ctrl shift P to select
react pure to state it's a plugin oh
cool you know what I totally forgot
about that so in the reactor food-truck
plugin which i do have for visual studio
code they do have a plugin for switching
from functional stateless functional
components to stateful component the
class based and it just automatically
does it for you
I forgot about that now that I you say
it like that was one of the coolest
features of the react foot truck when I
decided to download it and I haven't
even used it alright
Anna Anna has a question about where to
where do you see yourself in five years
I'm gonna think about that while we do
this code and then Anna when we come
back after this next coding session
that'll be the first question that I
answer alright
so I would do 25 minutes may not take
the whole 25 minutes we'll see how long
this takes to do what we're doing I do
want to make sure I have time at the end
for questions and that I do have time to
pick up my kids don't want to leave them
at school right okay all right yeah
here's what we're doing so let's go here
oops that's not a component let me copy
this paste and we're gonna go what do we
call that text section check section and
then down here right after our hero
section we're going to put our text
section here text section and we need
our props so scroll down make sure we
get all the props so let's try section
title and the section title is going to
be let's just let's go mission and text
for now be or remove some I need more
than that why isn't it an atom I had an
automatic like lorem ipsum generator
that's right I'm not worried about it
now I just want to make sure it all
renders text for the button link oops
button link we're just gonna make it
here so at least we'll have something it
will render button text and more it's
pretty standard and that's all we
shouldn't need let's see hopefully we
don't get some sort of error when they
try to render this stuff we'll see how
it goes
hmm it rose not to find where am i using
hero at 72 oh I forgot here text section
now that's where it went so I tried to
use multiple cursors to change this not
realizing that I had that text in here
as well so I thought I selected this
text but it didn't yeah it worked okay
cool so we have a section it says
mission we got our lorem ipsum text and
then we have our learn more button which
you can't really see because the colors
are off but not bad cool definitely need
some styling now let's see
so let's get to styling let's change
this class from parallax to section
and we're gonna add to this so let's do
some padding yeah we knew padding and I
want let's say let's try 32 pixels of
padding and zero on the sides let's just
try it out and for our button colors
let's give it
yeah let's switch it up and let's do two
one four one two a
cool all right let's see how this looks
all right nice yeah nice that's it
that's a nice amount of padding maybe
might one more but for right now I like
that let's let's put on this section we
do ever get her bottom on here - why
isn't it showing it let's see so we have
a margin bottom we should have
interesting
I'm not gonna adjust this until we get
more text in there because I need to see
it in the context like of what it will
likely be in and I we do have everything
centered right now which I didn't want
to Center but I guess I've I miss some
class on her I did a line item center
justify content starts let's fresh start
and I'm gonna flip it around is it this
one there we are
okay so depending on like where your
axis is reflects these could be flipped
around okay probably don't need to
justify content centers since we have
the padding at the top and bottom it but
I'm gonna leave it in there instead in
case we change it at this point we want
to set a probably a max
so we have this container whoops
we don't need container in there so we
need this container to be a hundred
percent with because if we put in a
background color we need that actually
let's put in a background color just so
that we can see exactly where everything
is background color mm say purple yay
how beautiful all right
so if I don't want it to be centered
then I need a container component so
let's put this in here I guess I could
use the grid container here and see what
it does let's try it out maybe the grid
container already has some built-in
stuff if it doesn't we'll just throw in
our own and then set it to like a
percentage with what's aesthetic
that's okay so I guess since I didn't
have this in the grid I'm not about
getting anything happening good item
okay so the hero button stuff is is
centering all right let's see what
happens now
all right now it goes over so weird all
right let's just switch this up instead
of a grid I'm just gonna make a div for
now and instead of container
this is close and ER container
and let's say with
max width is going to be 70 oops
70%
Oh
should I use margin:0 auto or is there
flex box thing that I should use we're
gonna say justify content or what did we
say it was
now this will work let's just do that I
see some activity there in the live chat
so I will check that out in just a
second container margin:0 auto and this
is just to Center that container
actually let's let's not do let's just
just do with 70 okay so that's gonna
give us our offset there
okay
all right now bad let me grab the
correct text so we could see what that
looks like when I say not bad I don't
mean like it's perfect I just mean we're
getting there
all right I really hope that the mission
is on the website like the short version
that I want
there we are
great alright so I was just grabbing it
on my other screen and let me put in
whoops the text here let's change this I
like to just use template literals
sometimes that way no matter what as
long as it's gonna let me do that no
matter what is in the text that we would
put in here whether it's single or
double quotes it doesn't matter it's not
going to mess anything up so on the
current website the title of this
section is mission summary I don't know
that I really want to keep that title
but that's what we'll do for now
usually questions about like content
like that
I just defer to my boss and lots so I'm
not gonna let me do that no seriously
not gonna let me use template littles
alright fine I don't know what I'm doing
wrong
maybe I can't use them in there oh I
can't use them because that's not jobs
everyone
all right so first thing that we notice
that's off this text is way too small
especially compared to this text even
with more text this still needs to be
have a bigger space so let's change this
to let's try body 2 and see if it makes
it bigger now it just makes it what is
that
alright let's stick with body 1 but then
let's give this a class name
oops classes
section text
and let's make the font size 16 pixels
and font weights 400 and line height 1.5
can I do that
I think I can do that
really today there's no way that's 16
oops yeah where are we getting this
oops haha I'm making lots of tiny
mistakes here all right let's say I'm
getting a call let me take this come up
yes
mm-hm
oh okay yeah I'm sorry I didn't get your
email so I don't know what happened with
that but am i sorry about that otherwise
we'll get back to you right away if yeah
I I need to make sure I checked that
folder more frequently so you can go you
can either there's a forum on the
bulletin on the actual website to submit
a new bulletin announcement so you can
send it through there if you want or you
can just send an email to bulletin at
Franciscan dot edu
every Monday Monday morning yeah I think
the cutoff is earlier today was the
cutoff yeah you could still give it a
shot and see occasionally some if
someone's like an emergency it does get
in but I can't guarantee anything oh
yeah no problem
all right sorry about that
good thing I noticed earlier that there
would probably be interruptions that was
so in the interest of just sharing with
you what my day is like it's a friend of
developer I'm gonna summarize that Cole
leaving out anyone's name a hug someone
called and asked for information that is
very much available on the bulletin
website asked how to submit something to
the bulletin well we have there in the
bulletin several buttons to be able to
submit and when you click it it has
instructions for the deadlines of
submitting so this person number one
called and said I emailed you yesterday
and you didn't get back to me so I'm
going to call you I never received an
email from that person so I let him know
obviously as you heard they didn't
receive the email right then they
complained about the email system then I
I let them know obviously how they can
submit to the bulletin and then they
said when there's bulletins come out
Mondays say oh it's probably too late
boy yeah it's too late
said oh well that's no use to me and
then you heard me say well it's worth a
shot you can
and they said I said oh well you know no
problem
and their response I think the last
thing they said was well this turned out
to be no use to me by that's I don't
want to say that's a common response but
it's definitely not the first time I've
had a call or an email like that I don't
know what's up here but I'm sure it's
not only this organization that it
happens in but there there are a group
of people that have certain traits in
common on campus that I don't understand
if you talk to them face-to-face they're
a lot nicer but via email or the phone
they just treat you like you're not
really a person I don't know anyway
obviously I'm not upset by it but just
wanted to share that with you that
sometimes you have stuff like that so
we're in the middle of developing a new
site and I get a call just explaining
information that we've already explained
in emails and announcements and
everything all right so here's what I
want to happen I want the font size to
be 16 wonderful and out 16 does that
look like it's still too small should we
make it 18 let me check the time - okay
I definitely got a hurry up here so I
can pick my kids up
I like 18 better let me know what you
think
I think 18 works much much better and
let's add in you know I'm not going to
add any padding to the bottom of this
because if we don't have stuff for the
button it's not going to render and then
I don't want to throw off the alignment
the vertical alignment by adding padding
so we're gonna add padding on the top of
this button and we're gonna leave this
alone but let's change this to 18 pixels
and it's really odd but people have been
freaking out way more than I thought
they would
about font sizes being larger I don't
know why but larger fonts are a good
thing it's easier to read you would
think people would understand that but
like within a certain age bracket of
people they're always like why is the
font so big so people can read it why
why would we not want people to read it
anyway let's do that last thing that we
talked about with the inverted button at
the grid all right so our hero button
that's what we're gonna put so let's go
with margin-top and we should give it
let's try eight pixels might need to
jump up a bit from there eight might be
too small that yeah I can't even tell if
anything happens so it's definitely too
small let's jump to 16 there we go
all right that's much more reasonable I
like that nice
okay unfortunately I'm not going to be
able to finish this component but I'll
tell you what I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do is just make these all
conditional so I'll do one just to give
you an example and then I'm just going
to repeat that for for everything else
so for the button I'm gonna say if we
get button link so button link and
button text then we will render button
otherwise we're gonna render nothing
we're gonna do null and why is my button
oh I need a space there okay so that's
what we're gonna do and then that way
too you see we have a button now but if
I remove even one of these so let's just
take out the button link and say that
see it doesn't render so we have to have
both to get a button to render okay so I
may I'm gonna commit this now so you all
can see it in github and just in case I
need to work on the weekend or something
happens next week and I can't come in on
Monday
I have everything even though it's not
quite finished let's let's do a git
status and get ad and yarn cm and we had
a new feature let's see create text
section
you ever look at a word and it looks
like it's misspelled but it's not and
it's where'd you spell all the time
that's what I just did when I looked at
component okay to run everything I did
to have to change one of the tests
earlier so when I changed the logo we
had some some unit testing on that
component that at bar component it was
checking to see that the filename of the
logo was correct so I I failed the test
so if you are doing any work on on any
of these repos keep that in mind to
check the tests I mean you'll get an
error it'll be pretty easy to tell
what's what happened because the errors
are our descriptive enough but sorry I'm
trying to find this password and talk at
the same time
so there's a descriptive enough but
that's where it might be and we do have
two folders for tests so we have our
unit tests and this folder up here this
underscore test underscore and then our
NN tests are in the e to e test folder
alright so if you wanted to test an
entire page do the end n test if it's
just a component you do the unit test
here alright let's just put that in
there we are now it should work do the
ssh ad so i don't have to worry about
typing that in again okay now I'm going
to answer as many questions as I can
before 2:30
it is 2:18 p.m. my time so let's see how
far I can go here and where I leave off
I know I left off in asked the question
about where do I see myself in five
years and that's I promise to answer
that first so let's do that
so in five years Wow five years in five
years I will have a teenager that's
crazy and it will be I'll be 37 Wow only
37 crazy in five years my beard might be
a lot more gray so depending on what the
style is maybe I'll do like that dyeing
my hair silver thing that people are
doing now but as far as where it goes I
I don't know we'll see
maybe I'll still be here maybe I won't I
actually I'm gonna let you in on
something that I haven't told very many
people I have a job interview for a
company in Pittsburgh next week so
somebody at that company found my stuff
on stackoverflow and check me out online
and I wanted to set up a meeting so I
had a phone call I'm gonna have to
finish a coding like puzzle this weekend
and submit that and then I'm gonna go in
and meet their team so my my job would
be full stack engineer if I get this
position so I don't know where I'll be
in five years I like it I love the
people here in my department so it would
be hard when I asked my my kids about it
about what I should do my son who's
eight years old said you shouldn't take
the new job I asked him why he said
because you like going to work and
seeing your friends so it's like I do I
like the people but I can't count on the
people being here forever either so if I
stay for that and then they all got
different jobs where would I would I be
so anyway that's a possibility yeah
odds are I'll still be somewhere in this
area like geographically because I still
have my parents and my grandparents live
here and I want my kids to grow up
knowing they're their great-grandparents
and and their grandparents so that's
gonna be that's gonna be there I would
really like though to be speaking at
more conferences and I'd like to be
doing more of this I know this is all
volunteer right now probably not ever
gonna be like a career for me but I
really do like doing this I like helping
people learn more about coding so
hopefully I can I can do more
I mean maybe branch out and and do some
more videos or who knows but if in five
years I'm still sitting here or in some
similar office talking to you all I'll
be very happy so hope
that was a decent answer also I'm gonna
be huge in five years like like
bodybuilder huge like I've been working
out in my basement and I don't keep
track how much weight I lift but it
seems impressive to my kids my kids
think I'm really strong so don't don't
tell them otherwise if you ever get a
chance to see him just let him think
that for now alright thanks for that
question and it was actually kind of fun
I didn't I've never really thought about
that till you asked it so I think that
was a good question for me
see
Oh Nicky says there is that that lorem
ipsum generator that like works inside
your editor only works between JSX tag
not inside props that makes sense I
guess I could do it elsewhere and then
just copy and paste it in really quick
John Henson says does this project use
code splitting or will it use code
splitting import for these large
components you've got on the go that
would be cool that would probably be a
feature that may or may not make it in
before we launch depending on what date
gets set for me to launch which just as
an aside it's kind of silly that the
launch date is now being set by people
who haven't even seen the website who
who don't do any work with website so
once you think I don't know I mean I
don't know everything about the
organization I'm sure there's a lot of
things going on I don't know about that
they're taking into consideration but
how can you set a launch date for a
product without ever even seeing the
product or knowing how close it actually
is to launching anyway hopefully after
these meetings
we'll be on the same page and and we get
a launch date in but anyway a little bit
off top of the question
but anyway John I yeah I haven't done a
lot with code splitting I think it's a
great idea and I'd love to put it in
this project at some point
let's see
John Hanson said asymmetry and web
design takes guts we've been programmed
way before the web and computers to
expect symmetrical balance and yeah I
everybody's like that but like let's
let's make it a bit bigger just to see
because on mobile you can't really tell
but I'll just make this full stream
right we have this full screen other
than like the weird purple color was
just throwing everything off right now
I don't think that that's that weird to
have this off-center a little bit like I
really I like that like to be honest
with you
I kind of want to see if I can do it
right here in the hero section and just
just have it off-center like that
everybody does this right I'm gonna
maybe try to do it like that and see
people are gonna freak out but I just
wanna see what it looks like I don't
know I think that would be cool actually
did that for a site I made for a client
before is I had hero sections with
titles but the titles were like I think
they were either down here or up here or
something so I did not have them
centered they were over here they had
just a slight margin it what's nice
about that is that you can clearly see
the title it's in that where they say
that F zone that everybody looks at and
then you can clearly see the image as
well I don't know we'll see I I know
I'll get pushback from that but you got
you gotta try to push stuff right if you
just make the same website over and over
again like it's it's boring and I don't
you you're like potentially depriving
your users of something that's a better
user experience or looks nicer you know
you got to try different things that's
the way I feel at least
Nikki says using the golden ratio makes
that bit of asymmetry look better the
golden ratio is super interesting oh
yeah you know what you're right you're
right Nikki maybe I'm gonna have to read
up more on that and how I can apply it
in here I imagine it's not it's a little
bit tricky since we're gonna have
different screen sizes but we should be
able to get it to work with percentage
with hey Quincy was in here I don't know
if Quincy still here but if you are
how's it going Chloe thanks for watching
the Quincy says watching Jessica Plus
listening to free code can't radio at
the same time oh that's awesome so if
you haven't listened to it yet free code
camp has this radio station going like I
think the goal is 24/7 so I don't know
if we're there yet but it's it's pretty
much every time I've checked it's been
it's been playing so check it out it has
music from from campers from free code
campers and it's it's cool so you check
it out and go in the chat chat with
people there's always been at least 20
people every time I've been in there so
it's pretty fun
let's see I see some more people saying
hello a house with one I might have to
but have to go really soon I'm really
glad that I committed that and pushed it
so I don't have to worry about it ah
let's see
Raphael asks what do you use for user
management in react we really haven't
done anything with with user management
and reacts so I can't really say we
haven't had a project that needed that
the only the closest we came is we have
a project that isn't it isn't live yet
it's still in in development and we've
had implemented like a password this
login system but we like we've tested it
it works but we've done nothing in terms
of using that information for anything
other than just logging people in so I
guess I don't really have a great a
great answer for that I apologize
now innocent do not be upset that was
when I was talking about that phone call
yeah I'm not upset I mean I I'm not
gonna lie
calls like that I mean you they don't
make you feel good right any time
anybody is is not polite you don't feel
good but it didn't get me down like I'm
not it's not gonna stay with me for a
long time I mean it kind of depends like
you all know a battle depression if I
happen to be really depressed right now
something like that would probably seem
a lot more you know terrible to me right
now but I'm feeling pretty good talking
with you all helps me feel better so it
actually happened at a great time
because I believe I'll be right back and
talk to you all so I'll be alright
alright looks like the size 18 font you
all think is is better so awesome I'm
definitely with you on that Jay Ryan
Rock says the Berg unlimited for many
sandwiches yeah if you've never been to
Pittsburgh for Manny brothers
restaurants have these sandwiches that
I've like french fries on them and it's
like a Pittsburgh thing I guess they're
really good Oh
Quincy said awesome good luck with the
interview thank you I appreciate that
all right Tiffany wait says hey I'm in
the burgh Oh awesome Tiffany that's cool
I always think like if I'm gonna be in
an area I should definitely let you all
know first and then if anybody wants to
like have a little Meetup that would be
cool so maybe I'll have to do a better
job of remembering that anytime I travel
or anything but I'm actually not that
far away from Pittsburgh like I can get
to the airport in like thirty five
minutes like not not speeding
anything just go on the regular fees so
so anything on the western side of
Pittsburgh is less than an hour for me
to get to and then like the other side
of Pittsburgh the eastern side takes me
a little longer but if there's ever any
meetups or anything going on in
Pittsburgh that you all know about let
me know I if I can I'd love to make it
hi I'm Jay Ryan rocks got timed out for
the for the bots for using cabs I also
say good luck thanks I appreciate it
I'm mission says good luck awesome
Quincy said when we eventually get a
chance to meet up in person and I
definitely like to hit the weights with
you yeah that would be cool
that would be cool I was feeling you you
definitely can lift more than me
I just started getting back into it a
month ago so this has been a month and
it's like 4:00 on Monday it was four
weeks I've worked out every single day
for the last four weeks so cardio
everyday and then I don't always lift
but I've only like some things I just do
like an ab workout so I don't really do
weights but I usually get in weights
like four times a week so anyway I'm
excited about that
I'm fishin s can you get into specifics
about telling what the puzzle is about
yeah the puzzle is I need to set up I
can use any language I want but I need
to make a program where it makes some
type of data structure that represents a
seating area so a certain amount of rows
and columns of seats of chairs and then
it needs to be able to I can give it
numbers of seats that I want and it can
reserve those seats and then I could
give it just like a number so I could
say okay I want five seats all together
and it can find the best five seats that
are available and reserve that so
assuming that the front row Center is
the best it'll use like a man what does
it call Manhattan something I can't
remain hatton distance or something to
determine where the seats are so I have
everything done up to the point where
you give it a number and it gives you
the seats so right now it's all command
line so it just asks you questions on
the command line and you type the
answers back but if I have time I'd
really like to build a front-end to it
because I think it's not part of the
instructions but honestly if I was going
to build that to be more to be useful to
more people it would be better if it had
a front end that was a web app than just
being a command line tool because most
people don't use the command line right
so anyway we'll see see how that goes
but that's basically what I mean it's
not it's not super complicated when I
when you break it down into like the
parts so hopefully I can get it finished
up you know tomorrow morning and then
that's really all the time I have to
probe to do anything this weekend with
it is tomorrow morning let's see what
time it is okay my kids school is
actually just let out right now so all
right I'm really I'm really sorry that
I'm not going to be able to get to all
the questions so if you have a question
that I didn't get to please put it in
the comments
this video or send me a message on
Twitter or Instagram or something and I
will answer your question but I have to
go now because my kids school is is out
and I have to I have to go pick them up
so have a wonderful day everyone have a
wonderful weekend I'll be back on Monday
and I really appreciate all the help and
has some really good questions as well
and let's see trying to find the off
button sorry yeah so I'll see you on
Monday I have a great weekend